listen i got some fun questions let's
see how this goes so
so first of all for the three of you
guys thank you so much for giving me
your time uh i really appreciate it uh i
listen i got a lot of questions about
smallville and some fun stuff but i
always like throwing a curveball at the
beginning uh usually an individual
question at one person and uh kristen
it's gonna be for you
um
i i am very curious about uh i love the
movie euro trip and i specifically love
them oh my goodness and i specifically
love scotty doesn't know with you and
matt damon on stage and it's it's an
it's all it's just an awesome sequence
so can you share what it was like
actually filming that and did you have
any idea what it would become
i
had no idea i was like oh fun i get to
go have a trip to europe
um
but yeah i mean it was weird we shot all
night long we shot in prague which
it doesn't need to be shot in prague but
we shot in prague
um and it was just dancing with
matt damon all night my legs were so
sore the next day
um i something so jumping into talking
for the three of you i am amazed that
you guys are all still like good friends
20 years down the road because i i know
a lot of i've spoken to a lot of people
that have made a lot of stuff and
sometimes there's no chemistry or people
hate each other on set what has been the
secret for the three of you guys still
being friendly
i i think for me it's it's that tom you
know we were all working so hard on the
show so the last thing you want to do is
hang with someone somebody else or some
anyone from the
from the set you don't want to hang out
with the people you work with on the
weekend especially tom who's working
constantly
so once the show ended tom and i tom
lived near me and we started hanging out
and it was like we got to know each
other because we never really got to
know each other chris and i are always
really friendly i think as a show in
later years for sure and i think we
became closer afterwards but um i also
think that the show provided a
foundation of trust
that you know kristin i may not see you
or talk to you all that often but the
second i see your face it's like you
know recognition with you it's like you
know i got you back like it's a say
that has been earned
um i mean
it's so funny that people want to talk
about a show that started 20 years ago
because to be honest a lot of the actors
don't remember what the hell we did 20
years ago
i mean that's the truth but at the same
time what you're seeing is this this
camaraderie that
really was
you know fortified in the trenches
during um
this making this show i mean
you know i i'm a much happier person now
that i was dead
he is i can attest to that yeah
yeah
i think you were so absorbed in like
work i mean you were working for
yesterday it was only once a year i mean
you were always on set and that had to
be yeah difficult yeah i know it's
difficult for you so i mean i wish i
would have known better then but i don't
you know now i know but that's how it
goes that's a life
yeah
here we are and you're right that but
but again sorry to give you a
you know
we developed so much trust between each
other on that show that i think that
allows us to be together and have so
much fun now yeah yeah uh back then 2000
you started filming 2001
the internet was the wild wild west
there was no social media completely
different world than it is now
do you think that if social media had
existed back then
that how would you think that would have
affected you
making the series back then do you know
what i mean because it's just
i know what you mean i think it would
have affected us negatively i think that
it was a distraction i think the fact
that we were in vancouver and we were
sort of isolated we were in a bubble and
that helped get better performances that
helped take away more of the
distractions and ultimately i think the
show was better because of it it was
very easy
not easy
when we were filming smallville
especially the early years the idea of
cell phones on set no one had to say no
cell phones on stuff now we all know
like
you can say no cell phones on set you
can like
there's still that guy who's like you
know this is a little text and [ __ ]
it's just part of our thing that we we
didn't have that distraction back then
and and i think we benefited from that
i i don't know if i would have been able
to it was i can't imagine what it would
have been like if there had been social
media and we had i mean i'm really
private tom was really private back then
i can't imagine any of us having a
social media account successfully and
trying to navigate sharing our lives
with people whilst also dealing with
working on a tv show for the first time
on a consistent basis there's just so
much or or having warner brothers asking
us to or yes totally right you know what
i mean like
yeah we you know we
that was good it was a blessing it was a
blessing in disguise
we're so lucky pocket of time i always
make the joke steve i always say i'd
have 10 million followers right now
social media was around back then but
you know it's like it's uh i'm glad it
wasn't i'm glad it was i think the show
is uh better without it
yeah it's interesting because back then
um
uh nowadays people in their contracts
you have to go to comic-con you i think
you have to do social there's a lot to
it to amplify the brand and to amplify
the show and you guys had that you were
in that pocket of time just before yeah
right you know
but anyway going back to
uh you you're you're making the pilot or
you're getting ready to make the pilot
what was your
uh like
joking around hope that how long could
this show actually last did you ever
joke around like
maybe like two years to the end of the
day
well i mean i'm not even joking like
can can we complete our day today
and that continued for 10 years they
don't tell you you're going to last 10
years in fact at the end of every season
you're cancelled technically
and
i think it's like six weeks later i mean
there were like four or five years that
you're the most successful show that's
ever been on the history of the cw they
still made you wait yeah like we knew we
were coming
so you never get to like sit back and
relax and chill
and other shows yeah
this scene this day
tomorrow like that's what it was that
was i mean that's my answer that's that
that was my focus
yeah i don't think i had even thought
about shows going this is my first big
show i like i don't even think i
considered
how long a show goes for i didn't it
wasn't even something that was a concept
in my mind i went to work i did my job i
met people i tried to figure this whole
thing out and that that was all it was i
feel like now it's very different going
into a show you're like okay how long
would this show run for how long do i
want it to run for
what do i feel comfortable with how's
the story best told i was not thinking
like that when we were doing small but
it's interesting you should say that i
do want to interrupt you on purpose you
did it because i never thought about
that because you're right i never
thought like i don't know how long does
a show last
since we did that i see it affecting
what i commit to now
because my
what i expect or what i feel like my
uh responsibility is
is not just one season or two season
it's probably not ten but if somebody's
like we're gonna do this tv show i'm
like all right well we're gonna do is
we're gonna do it you know what i mean
yeah so it it has affected me after the
fact more than did but anyway started no
christian you're right i i never
i agree i never was like i don't know
how long does tv show up i think that
for me
i had been on a lot of short-lived
you knew how shows didn't this last year
this lasted two this was a pilot this
was and when i saw this pilot i said
this show was gonna go i didn't know it
was gonna go ten years but i'm like this
is special this is just the style the
production value
the character
everything about it is so different and
so
not to say anti-wb
but it was nothing like the warner
brothers had ever done had dogs
increased new ground this is breaking
new ground all new ground was all brand
new and i felt like after seeing the
pilots like hol this is what i just
watched a movie
i just watched a movie in an hour and i
think this is gonna last i didn't know
if i would last i thought for sure i'd
get fired i really always did i thought
i'd get fired within the first few
episodes and then once i did a season i
realized
all right well i guess they're liking
what i'm doing but um i did think the
season would the show would go but i
didn't know how long
but
this we
we i've heard this question a lot did
you know it was gonna be
no no one ever tells you there's not at
one point that they even tell you you
can work the next day or the next
episode yeah it's a very sad reality
like until they give you the script and
the schedule for the next week you might
not be around yeah they didn't make you
know i don't think we ever felt like
you know i felt like they they were
passionate about the show they loved the
show but it was also a lot of work and
more money i think they'd ever spent on
a television show and they were kind of
figuring it out as they went along as
were we
and maybe that's the reason it's like
our days were so hard just to finish our
days and the cold nights and they just
wanted to you know we wanted to get done
for the day just to did we make our day
we have to carry me over and
the fact that you know it was the last
minute we got picked up
last few weeks we're getting we're doing
another season so we never had that
luxury of like other shows we're like
hey you just picked us up for two more
seasons it's so ridiculous like oh for
ten years i i would move into a house
move out of the house and move back in
yeah yep same thing because you you
can't settle you can't sell you can't
settle it was never really a settling
here the thing about smallville which i
don't think it gets enough credit for is
the fact that you guys came out in 2001
and it was right after uh the
brian singer's x-men it was before the
whole uh explosion of superheroes stuff
on the small screen and on the big
screen and i do think that smallville
you know got very big ratings the first
year i think that series your series
shown a light on what can be done and
and the popularity again of superheroes
it was right there and it was a
precursor to a lot of stuff do you sort
of ever think about that or do you
accept any of that credit i do i i think
that the show deserves a lot of credit
and it did you know there was a
resurgence of superheroes a resurgence
of new uh superhero tv shows and i think
that we were we were the beginning and
people saw what we were capable of doing
and that
that's why i think we have all these
shows now and i think that you know i do
give kudos to give credit to
our show and and everybody who's
involved in it because i think that we
were sort of the beginning
of it all 100
jokey question but i have to ask um so
every episode someone ended up in a
hospital like it was always a hospital
and ever if someone got hurt right a lot
yeah
in smallville this is for sure so my
question is did you oh 100
did anyone ever just want to joke around
and say on camera i can't live in this
town anymore every episode oh my god how
could i be in the hospital again how
could i have gotten hit in the head and
knocked down and don't remember [ __ ]
what is going on in smallville
uh yes we we there are very there are
many conversations about that people
don't care about that it's fine like all
right all you have to do in tv is have
somebody fall down and they forget yeah
i didn't realize every episode i mean a
lot of episodes i guess because i played
clark it wasn't yeah no you didn't end
up in the hospital very much
superman doesn't have a lot of head
injuries
no but i mean listen if when you have a
set that's the hospital
that means it's happening a lot
you make a solid point
you apparently do sir
yeah that was a good set i remember that
good points dude right just throwing
that out there so i do want to touch on
and you've touched on it a little bit
but i truly don't think enough people
realize and it's one of the reasons why
there might be a strike in hollywood
because of the hours everybody has to
work on making a tv series and you you
cite an example you mentioned already
the hours you had to work especially
with vfx but i sort of want to make sure
that fans understand what it really
takes to make a show like small villain
shows that are on today the hours that
the crew and the cast have to work
well i know for one that tom
in that those first few seasons we were
all working a lot but like you know
imagine tom who's a leader all
he's in every scene working 14 hours a
day he's waking up the next morning
they're trying to give him a quick
turnaround which is not his turn around
and he's got one eye open driving down
the street in the winter of vancouver
and i'm like we're not gonna have a show
if he doesn't make it to work and they
had to sort of make adjustments and get
them a car and things like that that us
as the cast sort of like presented to
them like hey yeah we need to take care
of it seems like an extravagance but it
was actually quite a necessity
and tom and then there are people that
are there
before and after tom
yeah
and those people work and they don't
have turnaround they don't have time to
rest
they get and and people get paid a lot
of money for this stuff but it's not
ultimately like is it worth it are
people's lives
that can you just pay people's lives off
and i i think it's really important for
people to understand that crews work so
hard
they work so hard and this is not an
easy job
it's often physical and grueling and
there's also a lot of pressure and that
pressure trickles downward
hierarchically and people you know you
have to always wearing this weight to
make sure that you don't [ __ ] it up and
and i think that
i just i wish that conditions were
better for everybody because it's a
crazy crazy job well how about this how
about the fact that
you know
12 hours is considered a normal you know
okay
you know
the rental on the lights the lights even
so whatever it is it's like you know
people work eight hour days they work
nine to five working nine two five
and it's like
you know 12 hours is a long time and
then you by the time you get home and go
to sleep you've got four hours of your
own life so you are and by the way 12
hours if you're lucky usually it's 14 12
and 14 hours of work then you get home
and they don't give you the drive time
so it's a lot it's not like you're
complaining but when you think about it
you're like i have about eight or nine
hours
that i'm gonna have to myself to get
things done in my life and so it's
especially the crew like kristen said i
mean it's like gosh i would it'd be more
appealing if it were only eight hours
none of us wouldn't
want to complain and get another job but
like it's not all it's been cut out to
be it's not as glamorous as you think it
took ten and a half days to shoot
an episode small though and what that
equated to was 41 minutes and 32 seconds
of television time
so there's a lot of work in there it's
designed
for the viewer not to see it like i get
that but it's hard and it's
it's it's what it is it could be better
uh it's a 12-hour day minimum because
that's the the rental on the lighting
equipment that's how the 12 days starts
and then it just
sort of spirals from there
um but you know it is what it is and you
know if if you're lucky you can
you know in another project you can say
i'm only doing this much time over this
map right now and it doesn't have to be
this way though i mean in europe in
europe in
other parts of the world they function
in a different way yep hours are
different people get longer lunches i
think that there are other alternatives
so and i'm not even talking from an
actress perspective because i have it
pretty easy generally i'm talking about
like the crew who's on the ground
i know 100 and look i mean the fact is
that also you were doing visual effects
on the series that were like ahead of
the curve in terms of what you could
pull off with your you were being very
ambitious on this series and um and and
that you know just people don't realize
it just takes a lot of time
yeah you know well i i
to jump on that we had guys like uh
greg beamon and glenn winter who were
visual like savants as far as like
what
what was accessible and what we could do
and how can we do it like not only were
we taking time to do it we were taking
time to figure it out super speeding
we had figured that out
over the course of like three weeks
it wasn't like an hour in the in the
back of the lot it was like we there was
a lot of time putting and then the
vision and all this stuff and you and i
have talked about this and some
interviews before but like
we finally got to a point in small but
was like the perfect scenario where
time money and quality came together
for visual effects to happen on
television
a year before it was not affordable or
more or less
and but we had to figure this stuff out
like nobody knows how what super hearing
looks like nobody knows what you know
what i mean like on television so yeah
we yeah we did all that i'm proud of it
100 so i want to jump backwards uh tom i
i don't think you went to san diego
comic-con while the show was on the air
or you went to the very end maybe you
went the last year
so
were you getting pressure during that
run to like actually go to comic-con
because uh i'm i'm i'm curious about
that um or and you sort of like i can't
like what was your sort of mental thing
where you're like i just can't go
the official answer i'll give you is a
scheduling conflict
each year they would say
comic-con 9 or 10 a.m in the morning
you know we're really putting smallville
out there it's gonna be peak time
the convention
and like it was like cool i'm still on
set saturday morning at six a.m
i physically can't be there until
so those two entities
seem to never figure themselves out
until
literally the 10th season
like i mean honestly it wasn't me not
wanting to go i mean yes i didn't
necessarily want to go because i was
busy but
at the same time i physically couldn't
be there in space and time
that's interesting i thought you were
joking around about scheduling but now
i'm realizing no that was really the
reason yeah that was actually the reason
yeah
we would work until six eight o'clock in
the morning on saturday
morning
well like how can i be in san diego at
10 a.m yeah yeah this goes back to the
hours thing i think again i just so many
people just don't realize um you guys
have been now you've done comic cons
together or promotional stuff in the
last you know and i'm just curious what
is it like
having a show
it's almost like star trek a little bit
where you're like you know you're 20
years after you have people still
wanting to talk to you about it do you
have a new respect for like william
shatner and everything he's gone through
over the years
i just have a
fun
brand new respect for the show and in
meeting people who come up to us and say
i'm so touched by this my father and i
when he was alive we used to watch us on
tuesday nights or whatever it means a
ton to us and now that we're out of it
and you know
it's just it's it's mo so much more
meaningful to me at least now to see
how and with hulu the resurgence of fans
and the show it seems like we've got a
brand new audience of course we're still
on tv and so it's exciting and it's
really cool and it's like you know i
feel like i feel like we're blessed
to have this in our lives i agree with
that i agree with i agree with michael
all right i gotta rap with you guys but
just real fast i read um that uh michael
you and tom were talking about an
animated series or something and i'm
just curious is that like a jokey thing
is that real no no we just can't we just
can't talk about it but we're like you
know
we're investing time and uh resources
and we're trying to
we're trying to make that happen with
the creators of smallwood well yeah with
the creators of smallville so we'll see
what happens
got it i am very curious about this
completely sincere actually um i have
more questions but i'm basically out of
time so i'm just going to say thank you
so much for giving me your time today
thank you
you know hopefully this wasn't too
painful and
and finally if i can help with anything
on collider in the future uh please let
me know we have at least five readers a
month
you've been amazing and make sure
everybody's in the podcast will you
inside of you with michael rosenbaum i
interview all these folks
so i appreciate you thanks doc 100 and
i'm sincere thank you so much thank you
you